よろしくお願いします
じゃあ今日のテーマは無我という言葉でございます
無我という言葉はパーリ語でアナッタという言葉を使っています
で アナッタという言葉の意味は
この永遠不滅な変化しない実体は見当たらないという意味なんですね
いわゆる否定形で実体はないという意味なんですね
いわゆる無実体論というよりは
非実体と実体ではないという
意味なんです  あの 無我について直接話し始めると
結構難しい話にはなります
で  2回目では あの 来月でしょうか
あのいろいろ経典からいくらか引用して
あの例を出して説明したいと思っています
今日は一般的なお話にいたします
特に私は単なるこの無我について喋りたいという気持ちはございませんが
無我についてよりは違うテーマに変えてみたいんですね
なぜ人間はそう簡単には悟り開けないかと
仏教の世界では この一生懸命修行している人々っていうのは結構いるんですね
で 昔から今まで それはまあ南方仏教とかね
まあ北方北伝仏教とか
そんな関係なく どなたでもまあ大変真面目に必死になって修行しているんです
修行のやり方 まあいろいろ少々変わっても
やっぱり目的は同じで
誰でもあの まあなんとか悟りを開きたいという気持ちはあるんですね
であるんですけど これ
なかなか悟ったという人々の数が少ないんです
でお釈迦様さえも人が悟り開いたら
これ大変珍しいことやと褒めるんですね
それでお釈迦様は特別に悟り開いた人々のことを特別に褒めてあげる
まあ偉大なる人々ですよと
勝利者ですよと 世の中に何ものにもとらわれない
あの栄誉 何といいますか
動物に例えたら まあライオンのような人ですよと
象のような人ですよと
堂々たる人々ですよと
それから聖なる人々ですよと
この世の中で聖者というならば
悟った人だけですよと
そこで何の仮りもなく
この世の中でまあ生きている人々ですよ
そういういろんな言葉で悟った人のことをお釈迦様は説明しています
いわゆる褒めているんですね
なぜそんなに褒めたかというと
やっぱり悟る人々の数が少なかったんだからなんです
で 仏典なんかね 仏典っていうのは経典だけではなくて
いろいろ仏典たくさんありますから
その場合は まあガンジス川の砂のように人々は悟ったとか
あだことか言ってますけどね
ああいうのは事実ではなくて
文学的な表現ですね それ真面目に事実に
ガンジス川にある砂を数えて
それぐらい人を悟ったかどうかと聞くのはもう何の意味もないんです
まあただ そんな大事な経典を聞いて誰もわからなかったと言っちゃったら
なんかちょっと格好つきませんだからね
で それぐらい人々は悟りましたとかね
で それは大乗経典でも
初期仏教経典ではなくて
この初期仏教仏典でも
そういうふうにたくさん人々が
悟りましたと それからまあ仏教でよく使う便利な数字があります
それは 8万4000ですね
で 何か経典をお経をお釈迦様が説法をなさったならば
その説法を聞いて  8万4000人の人々は悟りましたと
いうと 説法を 10回ぐらいしたならば
もう 8万4000人かける10だから
もうインドの人口 みんな悟りしまっちゃいますね
で 当時ではそんな人口いたわけじゃないし
またお釈迦様は南の方にいらっしゃったわけでもないし
ですから まあそういうのはあくまでも文学的な表現であって
そんなたくさん悟ったわけじゃないんです
でお釈迦様が自分があの最初に説法した時
初転法輪経という名前をつけてますけど
その説法終わったところで
混乱というお釈迦様 5
人の比丘たちの長老ですね
彼だけ たった一人だけ真理を理解したんですね
いわゆる第1番目のステージに悟ったんですね
お釈迦様はすごく喜んだんです
すごく喜んだんです あれほど 6年間も修行して
それは無駄になって それからもういろいろいろんな人に説法しました
何人かに説法しましたけど
あまりわからなくなったし
それでこの5人の自分の古い友達
まあ友達でもあるし お釈迦様は再起の時
自分の宮殿にいた家来の方々でもありましたし
その 5人の一人が理解したことで大変喜びました
なぜかというと それぐらい難しいことなんですね
お釈迦様にしてみれば
一人でもわかったことは不思議なことなんですね
ですから アンニャーシワタボウコンランニョ
アンニャーシワタボウコンランニョ
コンランニャだけは理解しました
コンランニャにわかりましたと
すごく喜びの言葉をお話しなさっているんですね
で そこまで行ったのは
この悟るということはなかなか難しいこと
そこでその5人の比丘たち
コンランニャ大長老が理解しました
それからお釈迦様はすきっきりで
残りの4人に受講やなさったんです
ずっと それでずっと説法したところで
一人 二人 4人 それで5人
こういうふうにゆっくりゆっくり悟っていったんですね
それ悟ったっても完全ではなくて
悟りは我々はステージ４つに分けてますからね
第1番目のステージですね
ヨルカと言うんですけどね
そこまで悟ったんですね
それでお釈迦様がみんな連れて行って 5
人にすごい大胆な一つの経を説法をしたんですね
その大胆な説法は無我についてなんです
で そこまで無我というと
言葉をあまり使ってなかったんですね
後でやっぱりこの4人はまあ一部はわかったんだけど
完全に煩悩は断ち切ってない
まだ煩悩いくつか残っている
お釈迦様と同等になってない
悟りの立場から見れば
それはよくないんですね
お釈迦様 は自分が悟った状況と全く同じ
みんなに理解して欲しかったんですからね
そこでどこで引っかかってるんですかと
わかったところで無我ですよと
というお経 経典を まあ今経典にはなってますけど
そういう説法をなさったんですね
本当はもう長い時間かけて説法をなさったと思いますけど
で 経典自体はそんなに長いものではないんです
まあ出典言って僕はパーリ版のページとしか持ってないのでね
日本の訳はちょっとわかりませんし
イギリス版の第3 サングッタニカヤというテキストにね
第3番目のあの 67 8ページ
ページ 2つしかないんですけどね
で その経典の名前はあなたラッカナという名前なんですね
あなたについて 無我についてお話をしました
それ 無我についてお話をしたところで
あの 5人も阿羅漢になってしまったんですね
いわゆる完全に悟ってしまったんですね
で それからも説法の下で 60人が増えたんです
60人の悟った人々が増えたんですね
増えたところで伝道開始ですね
こういう幸福な道をみんなに教えてくださいと
今 世の中で悟った人々が 61人いるんだと
私もあなた方も煩悩はなくなってるんだと
で 心は清らかになっているんだと
完全たる解脱を得ているんだと
ですから やることはないんだからね
これからは ですから 人々が苦しんでいるんだから
人々の幸福のために 幸せのために
一人一人で歩いて教えてあげてくださいと
いうふうに 世界初 この伝道活動ですね
人類初 で それで仏教はどんどん広げていきました
とにかく大事なポイントは
悟らない この引っ掛けはこのここにあると
無我というところにあるわけじゃなくて
無我と言わなきゃダメですよということなんです
実体はないと だから実体ないというとちょっと強律なんですけど
漢字いじってみると やっぱり非実体と言わなくちゃいけないんですね
いわゆる存在否定してるわけじゃないんです
実体はありませんと言ったら
なんとなくちょっと否定したようになっちゃいますけど
ですから  この非実体の物事の非実体の的な本質を説明したんです
そこであの大乗仏教に馴染みのある方々はよく知っている言葉がありまして
空という言葉が で 空という言葉は
このパーリ語でスンニャというんですね
サンスクリット語だったらシューニャというふうになりますけど
で あの 非実体であること
存在はすべては非実体であることをシューニャ
空だとお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
でもシューニャ 空ですよとも言い続けちゃうと
また論理的に道徳的にいろいろトラブルを起こしちゃうんですね
ですから それほど使ってないんです
一般的に同義語として
無我の同義語としてシューニャという言葉を使っているんです
シューニャというのは空ということなんですね
ですから この私は今日
シューニャあるいは空について喋ってるんだと思ったっても構いませんし
あるいは無我について喋ってるんだと思ったっても構いませんし
じゃあそこまで まあいくらか
まあ一般的な話で それから
このなんでこれ引っかかってるかというところから
このなんでそんな考え方
世の中であるんですか？とか
そこら辺ちょっと話したいんです
で あなたは否定形で 肯定系の言葉はアッターなんですね
それはパーリ語でアッターと言うんです
まあサンスクリット語でアナ
アナ アートマンと言うんですね
アートマン でお釈迦様から見ると
この人々はこのアートマン
アートマン あるいは我
あるいは実体っていうものはあるんだと
まあ人間 人類の初期時代からそういうふうに思い込んでいたんですね
何か実体があるんだ その実体も永遠不滅なもので
変わらないものだと思っていたんです
そこで私たちに何か永遠不滅なものあると思うと
我々はそれにしがみすぎて捕まっていかなくちゃいけないんですね
それですっごくそれにすがって
自分のアートマンに 自分の実体に
自分の本心に徹底的に縛りつけてもらっていなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
それは解脱という言葉の全く反対のことなんですね
解脱っていうのは一切を捨てるという意味なんです
何にもとらわれません
そこでアートマンということ
自我のことを喋る場合は
やっぱり自我だけはもう本心だから
本物だから それだけ否定するなってことになっちゃうんですね
ですから 自我を信じることで煩悩は消えなくなっちゃうんですね
心はきれいにならなくなっちゃうんですね
解脱は不可能になっちゃうんですね
そういうわけで 自分の五人の友人たちにも大胆にもう何も自我というのはないんですよと
どこにもないんですよということで
お釈迦様の 2番目の説法
まあ有名な説法として 2番目を教えたんです
じゃあそれから一般的に我々はその問題を考えてみましょう
私たちにもこの自我という概念はあるんです
ないわけないんです もしどなたかが私は仏教だから自我を信じてませんと
アートマン信じてませんと言ったっても
それは嘘なんです まあ信じていないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり心ではあると思っているんです
もしないとわかったら
その人悟っているんです
だからそれはもうそういうことで
どんな偉大なる仏教の人であろうとも
やっぱり悟ってないならば自我があるんだと
頑固と しがみすぎてるんですね
ですから悟れない引っ掛けそこにあるんです
ですから 私は自我無我のことを説明すると
皆様がそれを悟って終わるか
あるいは全く理解しないか
どっちかにはなりますけどまあ
だから中途半端で説明しようかなと
どのように自我論が生まれるのでしょうかと考えてみましょう
で 人間というのは大体生きていると
ものは見ていると すぐ頭の中で私は見ているんだという概念が生まれる
何か聞いていると ああ
私が聞いているんだと
と概念が生まれる 香りが鼻に入ると
私は嗅いでいるんだと
口に味が入ると 私は味わっているんだと
で 体にいろんなものを触れると
冷たさやら熱さやら硬さやら柔らかさやらね
あ 私は感じているんだと思うんですね
そこで目でものを見えたら
まあ時々喜びを感じる
あ 美しいと きれいと 耳から入る音についても
人間というのは喜びを感じる
で そのように我々の五根から人間
まあ時たま喜びを感じる
ずっとではないんだけど
それから物事を考える
その考えるものについても
時々面白いものを考えたりする
それと喜びを感じたりする
そこで人間が見たり 聞いたり
考えたり 味わったり 嗅いだり
触れたりするものについて
ああ いいものやと 生きているということはすごく楽しくて素晴らしいものだと思っちゃうんですね
なんて幸せかと 昔だったらね
森の中に入って獲物でも取れたら
なんて幸せかと みんな大変大喜びをしました
今の人々も もうそれなりに何か獲得したら
なんで私は幸せだろうと
というふうに思ったりする
そこで自分がいると錯覚が生まれるんです
私は考える ですから私がいると
錯覚が生まれるんですね
だからその屁理屈です
私が考えている 故に私がいるということは屁理屈です
なぜならば もう最初からもう私は入れているんだから
証拠なしに だから故に私がいると言えないんです
それは違う例えで言えば
ここに牛がいる だから牛がいると
何の意味もないんです
ここに牛がいると言ったら
もう牛がいるんです だからいりません
だから私が考える故に私がいるっていうのは
もう完全にもう屁理屈の始まりなんですね
だから仏教的に言えば
考える 考えるという働きがある
正しく見れば 考えるというファンクション
働きがある 故に私がいると言えないんです
その場合は なぜならば
私がいなかったら働きがないよということをまず証明しなくちゃいけないんですね
私は考えてるんじゃないか
だからいるんだと というのは
もうあんまりにももう幼稚的な
まあガキ的な考え方なんですね
でも人間というのはそんなにもう頭いいわけじゃないし
ただ簡単単純に私が見ている
私が聞いている 私が考えていると思って
それはどこにでも私が私がという言葉が出てくるんですね
そこでまとめて私がいるんだと結論付けちゃう
で 最初からもう私が見るということは解釈していないんです
そこら辺問題があるんですね
最初からも私が見るということは問題です
それで仏教で因果法則
認識論というものはできてきて
そこでどのように私が見るという錯覚が生まれるかと
そのプロセスを仏教で説明しているんです
そこで世の中の哲学はどのようになったかというと
私がいる そのいる私がどのようなものかと考えたりする
すでに存在している すでにここにある自我がどのような自我でしょうか
それは青いですか 赤いですか？とかインド人考えたんです
自分のアートマンがある
ある宗派では アートマンは青いですか？赤いですか？白いですか？黄色いですか？と色を 7つに分けてあったんです
そこで完全に心を清らかにした人のアートマンが白い色で
仏教の人のアートマンがなんかすごいひどい色なんですね
なんかもうものすごいまあ黒い青い色なんですね
で 仏教でないヒンドゥー教とか
他の宗教の人はもう黄色いとかね
赤いとか白い色に近いんです
で まあそれはその通りで
仏教では無我と言ってるんだから
まあ仏教の人々のアートマンの色は黒いと言ったってもしょうがないんです
その人から見れば否定しているんだから
で だから人間が何をやったかというと
アートマンについて考えたんです
自我について考えたんであって
自我っていうのはあるかないかとは確かめなかったんですね
どのようにこの自我という錯覚が生まれたかどうかは探してないんです
それはもうわかりやすい例で言えば
誰かに我々は例えば聞くんです
どこかのところに空き家があるんだと
その空き家にはお化けが出るんだと聞いたら
ああ そうですかと そうだったら
そのお化けはこういうこういうものだと喋るんです
それでもう一人は いやいや
そんなお化けがいるわけじゃない
こんな感じでお化けがいるんだと
これ いくら喋ったって無意味なんです
まず 本当にその空き家にお化けが出るか出ないかと確かめなきゃ何の意味もないんです
ですから 仏教ではこの合理的だったら厳密に合理的になりましょうと
具体的だったら厳密に具体的になりましょうということで
具体的に厳密にその問題を扱っているんです
それで昔の人々から見れば
まあここで自分がいるんじゃないかと
それから自分がいるんだけど
やっぱり自分に好きなこともあるし
嫌なこともあるし で どんどん年取って死んでしまっちゃうんですね
それはすごい惜しいことで
死にたくはないんです
なぜならば 目で見るものに囚われている
ああ 綺麗だと 耳で聞くもの
ああ 美しいんだと だから人間というのは生きていきたいというよりは
食べていきたい ものを見ていきたい
それだけのことなんです
なんでそんなにも生きたがりますかと聞いたら
誰も考えてないんです
ただ死にたくないというだけで
よく見ると人間というのはものを見続けたい
音を聞き続けたい 味を味わい続けたい
香りを嗅ぎ続けたい 体でいろんなものを触ったり触れたりしたい
ただそれだけ ただ生きていきたいということだけだったら
なんで年取ると悩むんですかね
耳が遠くなった 大変だとか悩む必要ないで生きてるんだから
それで十分でしょうに
腰が膝が痛くなっても歩けないんだ
大変だとかね あっちこっち走り回る必要ないんです
歩かなくたっても生きてるんだから
それでいいでしょうと言える
やっぱりそれでいいわけじゃないんです
やっぱり歩いたり ものを見たり
考えたり 聞いたり 喋ったりしたいんです
ですから 生きていきたいという気持ちは
ただ見たい 聞きたい 嗅いだい
味わいたい 触れたい 感じたい
考えたいということなんです
で 死ぬとそれできなくなっちゃうし
で 死ぬのはまたそういうわけで嫌なんですね
それも理解してほしい
なんか大雑把で やっぱり人間誰でも死ぬのは嫌ですよとか
生命誰でも死ぬのは嫌ですよと大雑把で言っても
それははっきりした真理じゃないんです
誰でも食べ続けたいと食い続けたいと
だから死にたくないと
もし人が食べるものに飽きてしまったならば
聞く音に飽きてしまったならば
見ることにも飽きちゃったと
それだったら元気がなくなって死んじゃうんです
それにとにかく人が死んでしまう
死んでしまうことはあまり好きじゃないんだから
やっぱりこの私というものは死ぬわけじゃないと
それに証拠をちょっとした証拠はあるんです
我々は小さい時からまあいろんなことを覚えているんですね
いろんなこと 全部じゃないんです
そこで私は歳でこういうことをしました
10歳でこういうことをしましたという
まあそんな素晴らしいメモリーじゃないんだけど
まあちょっといい加減で
まあまあなんかまあはっきりしないんですけど
いくらかは我々には記憶力ありますね
その記憶力で我々は言葉で私はという言葉で全部つなげちゃうんです
私は学校に行きましたと
私は今会社に行ってるんだと
あれは嘘です 学校に行ったのは子供であって
あんた今おじいさんでしょうし
おじいさんたちは学校に行かないっていうのは事実なんですけど
え？私はなんとか学校に行きましたよと
平気で言うんです 嘘なのに
で そこをそういうのは
この我々のわずかな記憶力と
この言葉 私はという言葉で全部まとめるんだからなんです
それから人間にもう一つ見えるんですね
世の中見ていると なんか自分勝手というよりは
世界を見るとなんかある一定の法則で
変 まあ動いているんではないかと
人間にはなかなかどうしようもないんです
世の中を見ると 何か一定の法則があるんですね
その一定の法則というものは
例えば米が 米が欲しい人は
リンゴの種まいたっても米は出てこないんですね
米が欲しい人は大事に自分の倉庫に籾なんか持っていって保存していたっても全然増えません
彼がそれを持って古くならないうちに
籾を 1年以内の籾を水田でちゃんとまいておかないと稲が出てこないんですね
それまた明日食べたいんだからって
今日種まいたっても明日食べられません
明日食べたければ やっぱり昔ですからね
やっぱり半年前に種まいておいて
面倒を見てあげなくちゃいけないんですね
それである法則見えるんですね
そこで どんな子供でも
小さい時は一番小さい時は泣いたりしたり
それから遊び盛りで それからいろんなことをそれなりに勉強したりとか
どんどん大人になってくると
また相手が見つかったり
家族を作ったり 仕事をしたりとか
で 年取っていくと あまりそういうことに興味なくて
まあ一箇所にとどまるようになったりして
どんどん死んでいく なんか自分の希望通りではなく
なんか違う方法で物事が動いているんではないかと
雨が欲しい時は雨が降らないし
欲しくない時も雨が降る
時々欲しい時も雨が降る
なんだこれという感じが生まれてくるんですね
そこで人間考えたのは
私は私の意志で歩いているような感じで
全部生命を管理者がいて
全部管理しているんだと
世の中の変化やら すべてのものはその管理者に管理されているんだと
その概念から個人の我と神我という概念は
歴史の中でゆっくりと現れてきたんですね
それぞれの文化で その考え方はそれなりに言葉違う説明ありますけどね
で この管理者はある個人ですよという神様ですよという概念もある
それは神様に名前もありますけどね
誰がつけたかわかりませんだけど
で あるいは個人ではなくて
あれは神我ですよとというふうな考え方もありますし
とにかく我が 2つあることは確かなんです
私たちの個人個人が持っている我とすべてを支配している
もう大我ですね 大きなアトマンという 2つがあるんだ
そのように言うんだけど
一人も証明していないんですね
あるということに 神我があるんだ
神様がいるんだというんだ
言うだけであって 本当にあるかないかと一度も確かめたことはないんです
一度も ただそうやって信じてくるだけ
まあ時々人間には魂があるんだけど
動物にはないんだという人々もいますけどね
動物は魂が吹き込んでないんだと
そう言われるとよく見えるんですね
何を考えているかと 動物を殺して食べたいんですね
だから殺すなかれと書いてるんだから
いるんだけど それ神様の言葉だと言ってるんだけど
やっぱり人間というのはまあ殺して食べたいんですね
そこで平気で自分を信じているにも関わらず
やっぱり動物は魂がないんだと
殺して食べてもいいと
それからまたあるグループでは
動物だけではなくて 人間も殺したいんですね
そこで何を言うかというと
神様は信じていない人はどうせ地獄に行くんだから
人間としては権利はないんだと
自分を創造して管理して
自分に豊かさ 幸せを与えてくれている神様自体否定しているんだから
もう生きる権利はないとということで
自分の神様を信じていない人々をもう何の感情もなしに殺すと
それで神様大変喜ぶと
これ人間が言うんです
神様が言うんじゃなくて
そのようにいろいろ複雑な宗教やら生き方やら
世の中の世の中に広げて発展していたんだけど
もともとも間違っているんですね
私は考えている だから私はいるというふうな
この西洋的な考え方と同じく
もともともそこら辺で理屈は間違っているんです
だから問題は 私たちのある問題は
この永遠不滅の何かあるかないかと調べることなんですね
そういうわけで まず仏教はまあ無我ですよと
我はありませんよというふうに
この他人の考え方いきなり否定するということはないんです
いきなりあんた間違ってるんだ
嘘を言ってるんだとかね
言って余計な喧嘩を作るということはない
その代わりに はい わかりました
そのあなたはおっしゃる
この我というものは アートマンというものはどんなものかと調べましょう
と調べることになったんです
そこで調べる方法が 2つあるんです
で わかりやすい方法は分析すること
そういうわけで 仏教ではきめ細かく物事を分析する
ギリギリまで分析する
究極なところまで物事を分析してみる
分析したところで まあ仏教でいう心の教えとかね
物質の教えとか そういう 2つが出来上がっちゃったんだけど
真我は見つからなかったんです
魂は で 分析するということはどういうことかというと
例えば皆様テープレコーダーを使っていらっしゃるんですね
もし我々はテープレコーダーの中にテープレコーダーたるものがありますよと
いわゆるもう魂みたいに
テープレコーダーはなぜテープレコーダーというならば
それでそれなりの実体
テープレコーダーたるものがテープレコーダーの中にありますよというならば
それを分解してみればいいんです
全部部品に分解すればどうなるかというと
テープレコーダーは消えちゃうんです
テープレコーダーたるものは見つからないんです
椅子という場合は 椅子たるものがあるというならば
もう分解してみれば とても簡単に
違うものに変化するんですね
それでテープレコーダーたるものは見つからなくなっちゃう
ボールペンがありますよという
ありますよと言ったら
一般的にはあります でも
ボールペンたるものが何かあるんだと言ったならば
それはもう分解してみれば
部品にしてみれば一つもボールペンではありません
それでこの正しいこの分析というものはした方が良かったのではないか
でお釈迦様は例えば見るもの
聞くものを全部ごちゃまぜにして
私は生きているんだということは言ってないんです
人は全部ごちゃまぜにして
私は 40 年間生きていたんだ
50 年間生きていたんだと
ずいぶん大雑把でまとめるんですね
それで何か実体があるように錯覚が起こるんです
そうじゃなくて 目で見えてるんだと
耳で聞こえてるんだと
見るものと聞くものはまるっきり違うものだと
全くも違うもの 耳で聞こえるのは音であって
目に入るのは光の波動であって
まるっきり違うでしょうに
今こちらに貼っているポスターは聞くことはできないでしょうに
じゃあ聞いてみてください
何も聞こえない それは見るものなんですね
じゃあ聞くものは見ることできますかね
見られません で 食べるものがあったならば
その味は食べて味わうのであって
見て これは塩っぽい これはしょっぱい
これは辛いとか言えますかね
見ては言えません あるいは聞いて言えますかね
おにぎりなんか耳元に持ってきて
あ これはこういう味だと
ですから 耳に入る情報
口に入る情報っていうのは全く別質なもので
それはごちゃまぜにまとめて私たちは生きているんだと言うんですね
それで私という実体があると思ってしまう
勘違いが起こる それは錯覚だと
そういうわけで 私たちにとってはこの分析する能力必要になったんですね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想というこの観察瞑想
物事をそのまま観察していく
それは瞑想ではないんです
瞑想というのは強引に何かをすることで
そうするとちょっとおかしくて
本当か何か分からなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 強引に何か観察するという瞑想はしないで
単なるヴィパッサナーというありのままを観察するという方法で
分析能力を身につくんですね
そこで一つ言葉を教えてあげたいんだけど
このヴィパッサナーワーダという言葉なんですが
ヴィパッサナーというのは分析するということ
ワーダっていうのは教えということなんですね
分析する教えという意味なんです
でお釈迦様が亡くなってから
ほんのちょっと時間経ったところで
いろんな考え方が仏教に入り込んだところで
で 問題が起きたんですね
じゃあ一体お釈迦様は何を教えたんですかと
どのように教えたんですかというと
お釈迦様は分析したんだと
物事を まあそういうことになって
今 上座仏教は上座仏教は我々の言葉でテーラワーダ仏教と言いますけど
で 古い言葉はヴィパッサナーなんです
分析するんだと 分析して
最後に何もなかったということを見つかるんだと
だから何もなかったということを見つかるのは
それ悟りの境地であって
それに至るためにはあるという思っているものを分析していかなくちゃいけないんですね
なんかヨーロッパの方にある哲学者がいてね
なんかこのモデルは天国にあるんだと
椅子の完全たる椅子の形のモデルは天国にあるんだ
で 犬だったら完全な犬の形は天国にあって
人間の世界にあるのはそれなりのそれなりのものだというふうにも思っていたんだからね
だからそんなものは単なる空想であって
何か証拠はっていうわけじゃないんです
体の観察はこういうことなんです
いろんな人を見てみる
見ると似ていて似ていない
そうでしょ？人間ってのは
我々でも まあ見てみればみんな同じ人間なんですけど
みんなに頭があって手があって足があってとかね
胴体があったりとかね
ほとんど似ています でも似ていて
またあえて似ていないんですね
背の高さが違うし 髪の硬さやらそれは違うし
肌の色が違うし 顔の形が違うし
目の形が違うし まあいろんな違うところあるんです
それから人間見ると あ
これ この人こそぴったし人間だというふうになかなか言いにくいんですね
なかなか言いにくい あ
人間のモデルはあの人ですよと
女性のモデルはあの人ですよと
男性のモデルはあの人ですよ
そういう人間はいませんね
どんな我々の目から見て美しいと
人にしても やっぱりまあそれなりに違うところはまた持っている
変わっているところ そこはまあ空想する人にとっては
やっぱり人間は似ていて似ていないということは
ある一つのモデルがあって
そのモデルからもうそれなりにいろんなこと
少々少々変えて変えて作ったんではないかと
作られたんではないかと
ですから 人間の世界にあるすべてのものにぴったしぴったしはなくて
理想的なモデルが上にあるんだと
どこかに それはある場所はやっぱり天国でなければいけませんし
地球でどこかにあるんだったら見つかるはずですからね
それまた我々 そういう考え方にも哲学というんですけど
それは仏教の立場から見れば
ただの空想であって妄想なんですね
勝手にものごと考える
もう何か情報があって考えることは確かなんです
気持ちはわかります わたり私もそういう人々がね
犬見ても犬はみんな犬なんですけど
えらい違うでしょうに
小さい犬があったり でっかい犬がいたりとかね
顔すごいグロテスクな犬がいたりとかね
すごいかわいい犬がいたりとかね
だからすごい でっかい犬
なんと名前かわかりませんけどいて
それからもう膝で抱いて飼っている小さな犬の種類もありますけど
随分違うでしょうし 違うんだけど
犬には変わりはないんだから
それだったら犬の基本的なモデルはどこかにあるでしょうということにことを空想は可能なんですね
そこでそのそういうふうに
この人間たるものとかね
我々の実体とかね 何かあるかとないかと見るためには
ヴィパッサナーという分析
分けてみる 一つ一つ丁寧に分けて見ることしかない
お釈迦様は自分がヴィパッサナーと言ってはいなかったんですけどね
お釈迦様は何をおっしゃるかというと
初期仏教の時代のお坊様たちに聞いたら
おっしゃったのは お釈迦様は因果法則と因果法則を教えたんだと
まあそれ 2つもつなげていますから
そんなに差があるわけじゃないんです
因果法則もあの 分かれば実体はないということを発見できるんです
だからなぜ因果法則を教えているんですかというと
やっぱり教無主義者にはなれませんだからね
仏教は無我だと言ったっても教無主義主義わけじゃないんです
何もないんだ だから平気だということを言っているわけじゃないんです
何もないんじゃなくて
いろいろ原因があって
それなりの現象が一時的に生まれますよと
で 子供が生まれたら確実に立派な大人に成長するかという約束はないんだと
子供はどんどん変化していく
その過程でどんな原因そろっていくかということに
立派な大人になるか だらしのない人間になるかということは
まあ最終的に決められますからね
そういうわけで この因果法則ということを大事ですよと
それで今覚えていただきたいのは
ただこれだけ この分析
ここに時計がありますよと言った途端
我々はやっぱりそうだ
時計があるんだと そこでそうだ
時計であるんだというふうに思わないで
時計って一体何ですかと
じゃあ一つ一つ分析してみようと分析したら針がある
針は時計ではありません
カバーがある カバーは時計ではありません
で この丸い文字盤 文字盤がある
文字盤が時計ではありません
電池がある 電池は時計ではありません
そこでまた中に電池動かす
なんとかなんとかとか
それなりの歯車とかありますからね
それ一つ一つも時計ではありません
では 時計は時計ですか？と
そうするとどう答えればいいんですか？その全く別な別なものがある法則でつなげたら
時計という一時的な現象が生まれるであって
時計はありませんと だから時計はありません
だけ言ったらダメなんです
時計はありません だってこちら実質に時計があるんだから
時計なんかは存在しませんと言ったら
なんかまあそれまたおかしい考え方で
そうじゃなくて 別々な働きする
違う違うものは まあある法則によってつなげれば時計なんですね
で 時計の例えばこの これはあのなんとか時計がポケットに使う時計だからね
この鎖をつなげる部分がありますね
それの働きは違う 針は別に何もしない
でも針の働き違う 文字盤の働き全く違う
何もやってない で それぞれ歯車や電池やらね
まあそれなりの自分の仕事をやってるだけで
一人も時間を教えてあげるっていうことは一人もやってないんです
時計の中にある電池がそんなこと知りません
ただ電力を定期的に出しているだけ
そこで電力コントロールする
このコイルやらいろいろね
クリスタルやらいろいろありますけどね
そちら時計のこと知っても全然知りません
自分の仕事をやってるだけで
だから歯車は知っても全然歯車は刺激やったらちょっと 1コマ1コマ飛ぶだけで
じゃあ針は？針はそれに繋げているんだから
まあ一緒に動くだけ で
文字盤は文字盤は別にどうったことなく
ただじーっと待ってるだけ
だから一人一人の仕事は別々なんです
それなのに我々には時計があるという概念があるんです
だから そういうふうに分析してみると
時計という実体はありませんではなくて
成り立たないんだと いろいろ仕事をまとめたら
新しい仕事は生まれる
目で見たら時間がいるということを我々にはできます
で 車という例を見ても同じことで
どこが車ですかと聞くと
どっちでも車じゃないんですね
車体は車ではないし 車輪は車ではないし
座席は車ではないし 燃料は車ではないし
ネジは車ではないし ミラーは車ではないし
一つも車ではないんです
鉄やらプラスチックやらいろいろものありますけどね
一つも車ではありません
じゃあだから車っていうのはまるっきりないかというと
そうではなくて 全く違う仕事をするものがある法則によってまとめたところで
車あるんじゃないかなと
ですから 車の存在っていうのはあくまでも一時的であって
一つの現象のみ 実体はないんです
それでさらに続けていくと
この 1つ1つ車の部品は車輪があります
といっても それさらに分析すると
また違う働きの品物が出てくるんです
例えばもう車にとっては空気っていうのは大変大事なことなんで
車輪は空気の上に でもあの車の重さやら全部空気で空気の圧力で支えているんだけど
そんな力空気にありますか？それでもないんですね
じゃあ私に空気の上に座れますかね？全然座れません
落ちちゃいます でも車に座ったら
本当は空気の上に座ってるんですけど
だからこの 一つ一つの現象はまた別々な仕事をしているんだと
それで因果法則と無我論はまあもう一体で
もう分離することはできないんです
分離して平気で何もないんだというのは興味主義的で
もう道徳的でもないし
悟りに関係なくなっちゃう
そういうわけでお釈迦様は
この単なる人の考え方を馬鹿にしたではなくて
丁寧に分析してみたところで
この法則とそれぞれの現象の働きは別々に見つかりましたんだから
それで無我ですよと 何もないんだと
人々はそれはわかってないんだから
我論にとらわれているんだと
それをわかった人には別に束縛はされませんと
ですから 因果法則を理解することをまた返って悟りなんです
無我理解することも悟りなんです
で 次のポイントは まあちょっと時間経ちましたので
皆様なんかすごい疲れるし
一方的に喋るとちょっと 5 分くらい休憩いたしまして
続けて話をします どうもありがとうございます
2回二部派でやります
であの無我ということはすごく難しく聞こえますけど
それよりもっと簡単な言葉があります
このアニッチャという言葉
それは日本語で無常ですね
アニッチャ パーリ語でアニッチャというんです
日本語で有名な無常という言葉なんです
それはわかりやすい で
無我にたどる道は無常にあるんです
無我を体験しても 無常を理解しても
また同じこと 全然意味が違うわけじゃないんです
言葉は違いますが 意味は同じなんです
そこでもし私たちには実体
本質 不変 不変なもの 永遠なものあるならば
世の中を調べると 私たちの生き方を調べると
この変化しないものがものを見つかるはずなんです
それまた最も簡単に見つかるはずなんです
もし私の体に我があるんだと
実体があるんだと 本質たる私がいるんだというならば
この体の中にそのものは簡単に見つかるはずなんです
一番簡単で 一番先に変わらないものだから
で 皆様はお魚召し上がるんですね
魚は口に入れちゃったら
一番簡単に見つかるのは骨なんですね
もし骨も入ったならば
すごい簡単に見つかるんです
口で なぜかというと 魚の方が噛みやすい
溶けやすい 壊れやすい
骨は魚の肉に比べると硬い
壊れにくい 噛みにくい
消化しにくい 変わらない
魚一つ買ってきて自分の部屋に置いておくと
すぐ変わるのは魚の肉の部分ですね
変わって腐って でも骨は全然
これ 1年  2年経ってもそのまま
ですから魚をさばく時も取り出しやすいのは骨の部分なんです
ですから まあそれちょっとした例なんですけど
魚の体の中に硬い 滅多なことで変化しない一部あります
瞬時に変化するも一部あります
そこで一番探しやすいのは
このめったに変化しない骨の部分なんです
それは普通の理屈なんです
それで人間に あるいは物事に変化しない実体があるならば
最も簡単にそれを見つかるはずなんです
見えるものであるならば
見えるはずなんです 舐められるものであるならば
すぐそれを舐めているはずなんです
聞いて発見するものだったら
それはそれで発見できるはずなんです
じゃあそれでお釈迦様はこういうふうにチャレンジします
じゃあ私たるこの私というこの存在を見てみましょうと
見てみたら何を発見するかと
全部変化するものは発見できますけど
変化しないものは発見できない
そこで自分という存在だけではなくて
客体的な社会 動植物 宇宙
何を見ても変化はある
いつでも変化して形変わっていく
で そこに実体というものは見つからないんです
ですから 無常というのは無我の教えなんです
で 人間には無我よりは無常っていうのは理解しやすい言葉なんですね
なぜ理解しやすいかというと
世の中を見ると 我々はこの悟りまで行かなくても
無常であることはもうちゃんと知ってるんですね
それなりに知ってるんです
本当に鋭く世の中を見ると
あるのは無常のみだと
何かあると言いたければ
どうしても だったら無常という抽象的な言葉しか言えないんです
人間は土から生まれて土に戻りますよというふうな言葉がありますね
で そういうふうに具体的な土とかね
そういうふうなことは言いにくいんです
本当に言えるのは そういう物体ではなくて
無常ということ 無常という言葉自体はちょっと抽象的な言葉で
別に無常 別にどこかにいるわけじゃないんです
物事は無常であるということ
ですから 物事の本質は我ではなくて無常なんですね
ですから 我々の今持っている知識で
智慧で世の中を見ていると
やっぱり無常は存在すると
無常という働きがあるということは見えますね
で 無常でなければ車は動かないんですね
車に実体あったならば動きません
そんな人が何かいじっただけで動くんだったら
実体ではないんだから
で 車に燃料を入れたら燃料は燃えてしまうんですね
それでいろんな部品が動くんですね
それで車が動いたということは成り立つんです
それ自体無常だから成り立つものなんです
永遠不滅だと言ったら
車どうやってある一箇所からもう他のところに移動できますかね
そこで私たちは生きているということはどういうことかというと
ずっと変化することに生きているというんです
最初は一個の細胞で命が始まりますけど
それは永遠不滅な魂があるんだったら
あの細胞はそのまま頑固と硬くているだけで変化しないんです
そこで人間は出来上がらないんですね
細胞は変化する 年取っていく
年取っていると これでダメやと思って
細胞は 2つに  4つに  8つに分けていくんですね
分裂していくんですね
分裂するためには大量に外から物質を受け入れなくちゃいけないんですね
1個の細胞を持っている物質数よりは
2個の細胞はもう2倍持ってますから
ですから 世の中からいろんな物質をいただいて
どんどんもう人間というものは出来上がっちゃうんですね
だから人間に何か無常たるじゃなくなくて
変化しない 永遠な我なんかあったら
これ大変なことなんです
考えてみてください 魚の骨のようなもの
変化しないものは 1個の細胞の中に入っていたとすると
あれ大きくなれませんだから
それだったら人間大きくなっても魂は変化しませんだから
だから人間に大きくなれなくなっちゃうんです
じゃあ魂も人がでっかくなるとでっかくなるぞと言ったならば
それは嘘です 魂は変化しないものだから
そういう哲学者はいるんです
体の大きさによって魂の大きさも変わりますよと
本当に欲の人間っていうのは屁理屈を言ってるんで
これジャイナ教なんですけど
インドの で いまだにすごい信仰しているんです
ジャイナ教は ジャイナ教の教えでは
人の体の大きさによって魂の大きさが違うんです
だから 象の魂がすごい大きくて
ネズミの魂が小さいんです
それでまた魂は全知全能で不滅で永遠であるとまた言うんです
それでジャイナ教も輪廻を信じていますね
そうするとゾウが死んじゃったところで人間にはなれないんですね
なぜかというと すごいでっかい魂だから
体ぐらい大きいんだからね
あれ 人間の体にね 住みこえませんだから変化しないものだからね
そういう風にも何のことも考えないで
ただ体の大きさに魂が大きいと平気で言うんです
でもだからといってジャイナ教僧様がでっち上げた嘘を言っているわけじゃないんです
彼にも何かあってそう言ってるんです
何かあるかというと 私たちはこれぐらい大きい体で実感が生まれている
160センチぐらい高いんだったら
160センチ背が高くて
これぐらいの体で私ちゅう実感がある
ネズミさんにはこれぐらい小さいんだから
それぐらいの大きさで私という実感があると
それは事実です ゾウだったらすごいでっかいスケールで私という実感が生まれてくる
その足を触ったら それは私の足触ってるんだと知ってるんだから
言いませんだけどね そんなことは
言わないんだけど 感じることは確かに感じる
だからこの感覚なんですね
感覚が体の大きさによって変化するんです
アメーバみたいな小さな動物の感覚がものすごい小さいんです
あの体にしか物事を感じられませんだから
その感覚が間違って その人々がちょっと誤解して
感覚から私がいるという実感が生まれるんだから
じゃあそのまち我ですよと
だから何のこともなく
体の大きさによって魂の大きさが変わりますよと
ということを言ったりする
そこで解脱したならば
ジャイナ教でもまあ解脱という言葉も使うし
カイワリャという言葉を使っているんですけどね
カイワリャっていうのは
まあ日本訳はどうすればいいんですかね
まあ絶対的状態というふうな意味で
まあ最終最終的な状態
最高な状態というふうな意味なんですね
まあそれ以上ない状態だから
解脱という言葉よりはね
涅槃という言葉は使ってないんです
で カイワリャという いわゆるどんな宗教でも言ってる解脱とのことですけどね
その状態になったらもう体はなくなると
それで普遍的な真我になるんだと
というと この魂っていうのは随分スケールが小さくなったり大きくなったりするものなんですね
だからそれ自体の考え方
おかしいと おかしいというよりは
やっぱり変化するでしょうと
お釈迦様から見れば あなたはおっしゃっている魂さえも変化するでしょうし
変化するだけじゃなくて
犬の魂が小さくて機能は小さいと
象の魂が大きくて その分機能も大きいと
人間の魂はそれなりであって
また人間と象を比べたらまた機能が違うでしょうしと
そこで善知のことを言ってるんだからね
魂にはほんのちょっとずつ智慧があるんだと
すべての煩悩が消えちゃったら
一切の智慧が生まれるんだと言ってるんだからね
だから魂はある時はほんのわずかなことしか知らないし
ある時はすべてのものを知るように巨大化するし
それ自体も変化でしょうに
物事を見える魂がいて
物事を見えない魂がいるんだということ自体も変化なんです
だからこの はっきり無常をわかってない
だからそういうふうな考え方が生まれるんだと
そういうわけで この無常という概念というのは素晴らしい概念なんです
それはものすごい発想というか発見なんです
それ発見したんだから
お釈迦様はやっと発見しましたと
真理を 真理というのは無常ということなんです
私はずっと変化していなきゃ
生きているということは言えません
食べたご飯はそのまま体の中にあったのは
私は病気なんです お医者さんにお願いして
この食べたものは早く消えるように何とかしてくださいと
でなきゃ私は病気で死んじゃうんです
で 食べたものは口に入った瞬間から変化していく
それからお腹に入ったら
腸に入ったら全部食べ物は消えてしまう
体から何を出すんですかね？食べたものを出しますかね
食べたものと全く違うものを出しているでしょうに
そういう変化があるんだから
私は生きているんだと
元気だと よく食欲はあるんだと
よく食欲あるという人は
もう大量に食べても全部早く変化して消えるということ
食欲ないなという人は
まあたくさん食べても早く変化しないということなんです
ですから ほんのちょっと食べてる
それもやっと苦労して変化させると
だから変化自体は生きているということなんです
光の波動が目に映ったら
目の中で変化が起こらなきゃ見えますかね
見えませんし その中で脳の中でありとあらゆる変化が起こらなきゃ見えたということになりませんし
で 私は今喋ってるんだから
あの食べたご飯のエネルギーはずっと消えていくでしょうし
消えたところでもう力がないんだとふうなことになるでしょうし
子供が生きてるんだというのことは
子供はずっと変化して生きていることなんですね
だから変化でなければものは成り立たない
私はよく言う例がありまして
バイオリンというのは楽器なんですね
そこに変化がなければ音が生まれますかと
あのバイオリンの弦と弓というんですか
ボウと英語と言いますけどもね
弓が触れて そこに空気の中に変化を起こしちゃうんですね
それで音楽というんです
何も変化しなきゃ そこで音楽はないんです
それだったらうるさくてしょうがなくなっちゃいますからね
ピアノやらバイオリンやら太鼓やらドラムスやらね
ただ そのまで音楽だったら
まあこの世の中でいたもんじゃないんだよ
うるさいんだから やっぱり誰かがドラムセットにしたっても
変化を起こさなきゃそこに音が生まれませんね
そこで我々は種をまいたりする
その種は完全に消えてしまわなきゃ芽があるわけじゃないでしょうに
その芽ということをまたどんどん消えて大きくならなきゃ
我々に必要な植物は出てこないでしょうに
毎日世の中を見ていると
瞬間瞬間 すべてのものは変化する
変化する 変化するんだからあるんですね
ですから あるというならば変化なんですね
存在というならば 変化は存在である
まあある意味 変化は変化と読む場合もありますけど
仏教用語でね まあそれぞれまあ発音はどうでもいいんですけど
ですから 変化っていうのは無常ということで
そのままではいられないんです
じゃあ時計は時計ですよというためには
この時計は変化しなきゃ時計ではないんです
それだと私は時計壊れているんだと
なぜなら 時計見ると針はそのまんまだったら壊れているでしょうに
だからそこに変化が起きているんです
それ止まらない その変化は
そこで電池は切れるし
そこで時計は止まっちゃうし
それで電気入れたらまた動き始めます
始まりますし じゃあ電気を入れないで置いておけばどうなるんですか？時計は
それでも変化する だから変化だけは止まれません
じゃあ人間は引いて やっぱり何か永遠不滅なもの欲しいんだというならば
変化は永遠不滅だよということは言えますけど
それまあ言葉の遊びですけどね
永遠不滅なものといえば
無常ということ 永遠不滅だと
それをお釈迦様は言うんです
万物は無常であることは
過去でも無常でしたと
今も無常でしたですと
これからは無常ですよと
だから仏教では真理を語っているんだと
時代が変わっても真理は変わりませんと
じゃあ仏教は古臭いかと
今２６００年経ってるんだから
お釈迦様が生まれて あ
仏教は古臭いんだと そんな古い話なんか
現代科学時代のインターネット時代の通信時代の我々にはどうかと
そんなことありますかね？そんなことはないでしょうし
無知なる過去も物事は無常だから存在したんであって
現在で物事は無常だから存在するんであって
将来もそうでしょうし
だから無常こそ真理なんです
花が咲くのも花が散るのも無常だからでしょうし
植物は今はね まあどんどんもう黄色くなっていくでしょうね
葉っぱなんかは それは無常でしょうし
それで葉っぱが落ちて
何もことなくじっと寝ているでしょうに
冬になったら寝ているわけじゃないんです
それでも生きているんですけどね
それもまた無常でしょう
それで春になってくると
一斉に花が咲いたりし
まあ新緑が出たりするでしょうし
そんなことを止まってみてください
それで死の世界でしょうに
生の世界じゃないんです
だからこの人々は この実体があるんだと
変化しないものはあるんだという人々はあんまりも無知なんです
変化しないものあるということは
もう死の世界なんです
変化するんだから 世の中には生の世界生きているんです
変化があるんだから もう私にはもう努力したっても構いません
例えば 私には絶対的な魂があるんだと思い込んじゃったら
私は何やろうと魂は絶対的だから変化しないでしょうに
人殺しても あるいは人を助けてあげたっても
まあ魂は知ったことじゃないんですね
変化しませんだから でも
体の中に変化しないものは一つもないんだから
私は悪いことをすると悪い人間になる
いいことをするといい人間になる
それで今まで悪いことをしてきた人間が
じゃあこれからいいことをしますよと思ったら
それからいい人間になる
今までいいことをしてきた人間が
これから悪いことをしましょうと思ったら
それから悪い人間になってしまうんじゃん
そういうわけで 変化あるんだからこそ
人間の努力の意味があるんです
人間に希望通りのことをできるんです
我々の希望通りのことをできるためには
無常でなければいけません
それなのに この我があるという言っている人々は
真我は自由自在だと言うんです
絶対的で普遍的で まああの
何て言いますか 普遍的ではなくて
このまあ永遠なもので
変化しないもので また自由自在だと
ありえないでしょうに
そんなことは 絶対的なものだから
何のために自由自在ってある必要あるんですかね？大きくなったり小さくなったりとかね
長くなったり短くなったりとか
そういう自由自在になる必要ないでしょうに
絶対的なものだから だから世の中で本当にもうそれほど無知な考え方はないんですけど
すべての人類は我論にいるんですね
我があるんだと そういうわけでお釈迦様は悟ってない人に使っている言葉が何でしょうかね
愚か者という言葉を平気で使っているんです
盲目取り去ってよとか愚か者
あれは別に貶している言葉ではなくて
やっぱり無明に覆われている人々や
で これほど我ほど非合理的な非論理的な考え方がないんです
どう観察してみても 世の中は変化に変化の上で変化変化で成り立っているんです
世の中で変化できなければ
どうやって飛行機作られますかね
あんな何万トンも重いものをよく空は飛ぶでしょうに
変化だから可能なんです
物事をまあ全く別な仕事をするものごと
空は飛べそうもないものごと集めて
それで空を飛ばしちゃうんですね
1000人も人を乗せて
人の荷物まで乗せて行くんだから飛ぶんだから
それは無常だから成り立つんですね
同時に因果法則も成り立つんです
どういうことかというと
誰かが飛行機作る材料を私のところに持ってきたっても
私が作った飛行機に乗らない方がいいんです
それは空を飛ぶところが 1 メートルの先にも行かないかもしれません
一番先に運ぶためには
すごい巨大なトラックでも使って使わないと
なぜかというと 私は飛行機の因果法則わかりません
だから作れません 空を飛ぶという場合は
好き勝手に飛ぶわけじゃなくて
それにはそれなりの法則もあるんです
人間 子供を作るんだと思ったって
やっぱりそれなりの法則があるんです
その法則によって子供を作るんだけど
変化がなければそれでも子供は生まれませんね
だからその変化と因果法則はまるっきり理解しないんだから
全部神様に決められているんだと
そこで科学者たちが DNA の研究をやってみようと
遺伝子改変でもやってみようか
面白いぞと思っちゃうと
神様の神様の領域を侮辱するんだと犯すなと言うんですね
何の根拠であんなことを言ってるんですかね
今まで神様の領域を侵しちゃったんだから
このような世界があるんだから
犯したいほど犯した方がいいんです
神様はやってはいけないということが何かあるならば
必ずしもやった方がいいんです
そうすると幸福になるんです
不思議な話なんですね
で まあ本当は神様はそんなこと言ってるわけじゃなくて
大馬鹿者どもがね 聖書という文学作品を書いているだけであって
そこに乗っ取られ惹かれているだけのことなんですけど
神様みたいな この絶対的な管理者がありえないしね
法則によって成り立っていることはわかってないだけで
そこで私たちは無常ということを理解できれば
そこに実体がないということ見えてくる
で じゃあ音について考えましょう
どこかから音が生まれてくる
音っていうのは 瞬間しか 1 秒に大体 40万回でも変化しなきゃ音ではないんです
それぐらい変化するエネルギーは耳に触れると
それなりなりに頭の中にいろいろ変化を受けて
聴覚っていうものは生まれる
それで感覚も生まれる
考え方は生まれる 面白い音だと
綺麗な音だと 感動できる音だと
うるさい音だと 我々考え方は生まれる
そこで実体ありますかね？そこに実体はないんです
車と同じ 花と同じく変化の過程なんです
なぜかというと 耳に入っている音
時々気持ちはいい 時々気持ちは悪い
時々は感動する 時々は腹が立つと
ただ音を触れるだけ ですから
感情というものもずっと変化していますね
私は今泣いてるんだという人は
あと時間経つと笑っている
そこで私は笑っているんだと
その時は その人は精神的に全く違うんですね
変化しているんです もし我々に変化しない主体があるならば
私は何喋っても全く変化ないはずなんです
今日私はすごく気をつけて喋っているんですけど
もっと大胆なことを言いますけどね
で 今日すごい気をつけて喋ってるんです
人の気に障る 触ることはできるだけ控えましょうと
で あの そういう変化しない主体があるならば
私は何言ったっても平気なはずなんです
最近ある人が来て 大乗仏教を批判するなと
僕の頭にあんた痛いんですか？と聞きたかったんだけどね
痛いんだったらこっち来るなと
だからもう馬鹿なことを
僕は大乗仏教の人じゃなくて
正真正銘の小乗仏教というか
浄土仏教の坊主だから
自分の仏教を語るしか何を
私はキリスト教を語ればいいんですかね
神様を信じたまえとか
皆様方は他人の宗教を批判するのは
それはけしからんなことでね
平和のために良くないし
私はそう言わなきゃいけないでしょうに
お医者さんは人を斬らなくちゃいけないんです
外科であるならば 人を斬ってはいけませんと
人を斬ったらもう犯罪でしょう
人のお腹が斬ったり 胸を切ったりとかね
斬るのはいいんだけど
取っちゃうんですね 中にあるものは
これ犯罪のいいところなんですね
でも外科の医者はそれやらなくちゃいけないんです
それは犯罪に犯罪じゃないんです
それなのに批判するなと
それは大乗仏教の方々から見れば大変失礼だと
わかってます そんなことは
私は言われる人はどれほど馬鹿者かと
でもそれ私は言えませんだからね
ああ そうですか よくわかりましたと
ものは済んだんだけど
ものは済んだんだってことは
頭の中で違う 違う考え方はありますけどね
なんと言わんほかと そうじゃなくて
言いたければ まあ批判するんだったら
もうなんて言いますか
聞く側にも納得いけるように
ただダメですよ ああだこうだというんじゃなくて
ちゃんと根拠があって
証拠を出して 批判される側にも納得いけるように言った方がいいんじゃないかとアドバイスした方が
それ立派なアドバイスなんですけど
まあとにかく私は言いたかったのは
我々には変化しない主体があるならば
私は何言ったっても構いません
心の中 変化しないはずなんです
でも私はちょっとでも気に障ることと言ったならば
やっぱり気に障ってしまって気持ちが悪くなる
面白いことを言ったならば
すぐ面白くなって笑ったりする
そこでもう変化でしょうね
もし主体があるならば
お釈迦様みたいなブッダたちがもうガンジス河の砂のごとく
砂のごとく来て説法された人は悟りません
主体があるんだから変化しない
ですから 不幸というならば
すべては無常ですよという言葉自体は不幸なんです
神が作ったよっていうのは不幸ですね
不幸のメッセージ あなた方にはどうすることもできないんだと
もう作られてるんだと
操る人形だけですよと
どうったことないんだと
生命を貶してるんですね
馬鹿にしているんです
あなたには何ができるかと
ある そういう神様を信じている人が私に言うんですね
あなたにできますかね？あなたの白い髪の毛でも黒くすることはできないでしょう
だから神様は全部管理しているんだと
僕は何も言わなかったんだけどね
で だから聞きたかったのは
なんで神様は人間に嫌なことばっかりやるんですかと
例えば年取りたくないでしょ？私も年は取りたくくないんです
嫌なんです 正直なところ
嫌ですけど 年取るんですね
どうしようもないんです
それで神様を信じる人は
だからほら ご覧なさい
あなたに何もできない
それは中央的な中央管理局で
あなたは管理されているんだと
それ管理されてるのはいいんだけど
なんで嫌がらせばっかりやってるんですかと
嫌がらせだけでしょうに
生きるということは 例えば
皆様方 どれほど苦労するんでしょうかね
もうただ家賃払って もう毎日の食べ物と服とかね
薬とか それぐらいのことしかできないでしょうに
一生仕事したっても それも嫌がらせでしょうね
なんでそんなに苦労しなくちゃいけないんですかね
生きるために 猫みたいに餌もらったらもう食べて
また褒めてもくれる いい子だ
いい子でよく食べてるんだと
なんで立派な人間にそんなことないんですかね
ですからまあ 私 そういう管理局で管理されているわけでもなく
管理されていると言われたら
それはまあ不幸であって
福音ではないんです なぜならば人間は貶されている
努力は否定している 人間に努力できれば
管理局はどうするんですかね
例えば 日本には法律というものがあるんですね
その法律で我々はもう管理されているんですね
私たちにはどうすることもできないんです
いくら叫んでも 法律を犯しちゃったら
もうもうそれでそれなりに裁かれるし
それはやっぱり管理局で管理されているんです
ちゃんと法律のことを管理するシステムできているんだから
私たちのすごい仲のいい警察のお巡りさんがいたっても
その同じ人来て私を捕まっちゃうんです
悪いことしちゃったら
じゃああんた友達だからいいですよと言いますかね
言いません その時は ですから
この管理されているよということ自体は不幸だと
私は悪口なんですけど
言いたいんですけどね
だから我々は管理されてないこと
その代わりに法則によって変化しているということ自体が人間にとって不幸なんですね
ですから お釈迦様はこの
幸福のメッセージをありとあらゆる人間に話しながら歩けと
無常ということは幸福の言葉なんです
無常 すなわち無我なんです
なんで無常に私は乗り移ったかというと
その方がわかりやすいんですね
無我ということは やっぱりすごいインド的なんですね
考え方は インド的というか
まあそういうアーリア系の人間の考え方ですね
いわゆる実体は確実にあるんだと
主体はあるんだと 日本的じゃない
日本はもう知らない そんなあるかないかも知らない
とにかく南無阿弥陀仏とか
なんか成仏とかね それぐらいで大雑把に物事を済みますから
それほど我っていうことはあまり気にしないだろうと思います
でも人間だからね 日本の方々はも
やっぱり何か霊魂か何か魂か
何か変化しないものはあるんだとは思っているんですね
だから人を死んじゃったら成仏させますからね
成仏したかどうかはわからないんだけど
これでよかった 成仏できてというか
何の証拠もないのに やっぱり
で 自分一人で喜んじゃうんです
死んだ人はどうか分かりませんだけど
お墓の前にお蕎麦とかね
酒 あの あの あの 何といいますか
カップ酒とか置いて まあそれでよかったと
で そんなまあ食べるか飲むかどうか分かりませんだけど
まあとにかくそういう習慣から見えるのは何かというと
やっぱりおじいさんが死んでないということなんですね
おじいさんが酒好きでしたからね
じゃあお供えしましょうと
酒好きでしたのは 生きてた人間でしたけどね
死んだもの酒飲んで酔っ払ってどうするんでしょうか
わかりませんしね もし幽霊になってて酒飲んじゃったら
もうとんでもないことになりますけどね
まあとにかくそういうことを考えずに
まあただ酒好きだったら酒をお供えするし
ご飯好きだったらご飯をお供えするし
なんとかする そういう習慣の中にも
やっぱり人間の感情っていうのは入ってるんですね
やっぱり何か続けて変化しないものは何かあるんだと
このシュンゲタ空論の場合は
最初は全部幻だよと 主体実体ないんだよと
幻覚だよと 蜃気楼だよと
頭に映る概念だけですよと
現象ですよとという教えでしたけど
やっぱりどんどんその空論というものが発達して
空自体が実体だよと言ってしまったんです
お釈迦さん 普通の人だったら殺しちゃいます
その人々は 私が言ったこと正反対のことを言っているのではないかと
でまあとにかくやっぱり人間
こういう風に空想続けちゃうと
最後にまた実体論に止まってしまっちゃうんです
しょうがないんですね
どうしようもないんです
まあとにかく我々は無常ということをわかりやすいんだから
無常をよく理解して時を理解する
無常ということを理解すると
無常だから生きてるんだ
無常だから蛍光灯が光ってるんだ
無常だから私は喋ってるんだ
無常だから私の言うことを理解できるんだということもわかるでしょうし
無常だからご飯食べられるんだと
無常だから食べたご飯は消化できるんだと
あ 無常だから存在というこの働きがあるんだと
そこで問題は 全部無常だから
どこに私はと言うんですかという問題なんです
ね 変化するんだから そこで今私はと捕まったものは
1時間経って捕まえていると全く別なものなんです
リンゴの種まく そこでそれはその時のもので
で  1年経ってところで
前私はリンゴの種を手で握っていたんだよと
まいたところで  1年経ったところで握るのはリンゴの種ですかね
全く別な木なんですね
そこら辺は理解できれば
もう悟りの境地にはもうなんとなく近寄る可能性はあります
だから母親は私はよく言う同じ例えなんですけど
母親は産むのは赤ちゃんなんです
で これ 30歳ぐらいの大きな男
大大人見て 甘え 私は産んだ子供ではないかと
じゃああれ 嘘でしょうし
あんなでっかい人は産むわけにいきませんし
産めないでしょうに 自分を産んだのは小さな赤ちゃんであって
その人はもう変化して変化して全く別なものになっている
全く別なんです そこで
まあ囚われる取る取るものはないんだと
例えば自分の子供の体の中で
私の子はこの部分だよというものは何もないんです
赤ちゃんちゃんの体 全部私の子供だよと言ったっても
その体全部消えちゃいますから
お母さんに子供がなくなっちゃうんです
10歳ぐらいになっちゃうと
そこで因果法則というものが成り立って
一つ変化するということは
違うものに変化する あるいは新しいものが生まれる
変化するということは
新しいものが生まれなきゃ変化ではありません
それもまたごく普通なこと
あ これ変化しましたよというと
新しいものが生まれたということなんです
例えば壁に色が塗ったとする
で 拭かないで置いておいたら
1 年間ぐらいとかね まあ私たちはよく経験ありますけど
自分の国ではいくら色を塗っても
もう 3ヶ月とかになって立ってみたところでは色がないんです
もう消えているんです
まあ太陽の光が強いんだから
そこで塗った青い色が変化したんです
太陽の光に当たって変化して
違う色になった だから変化の法則っていうのは
消えて違うものを生まれる
生まれたものは全く違うんです
じゃあ 米とご飯は全く同じものですか？同じものじゃないでしょうに
米は食べられませんし
おいしくもないし で 米からご飯生まれますけど
ご飯はおいしいし 柔らかいし
食べられるし 食べたら体が元気になるし
で 米食べたら硬いしおいしくないし
食べたらお腹が壊すし
消化不良になる 食べてみてください
消化できなくなっちゃうんです
だから ご飯の中に米の魂が入ってるわけじゃないんです
米自体が変化してご飯になったんです
ご飯食べたところでご飯は消えちゃったんです
消えちゃって違う変化を起こしているんです
それで今私は食べたご飯で喋ってますけど
どんなご飯で喋ってるかわかりますかね？もうわからない
もう消えちゃったんだから
子供は遊んでいると まあ朝何か食べさせたんだと
まあパンやらいろいろもの食べ
まあヨーグルトやら食べさせたんだと
そこで昼はまあもうラーメン食べさせたんだと
そこで子供は 2時から 4時まで遊んでいると
2時から 2時半まで あれはパンのエネルギーで遊んでいるんだと
2時  2時 10 分から 15 分
15 分まで あれは卵のエネルギーです
わかりますかね そんなことは
さっぱりわからないでしょうに
もう変化しちゃったんだから
もうすでにそこに何もないんです
あ らしいものが生まれているんです
ですから つかまるもの
執着するべきもの ありがたいものっていうのはないんだから
無執着の心境心を作ると
だからといって じゃあ道徳は成り立たないかと
成り立つんです なぜかというと
米がなかったらご飯は生まれませんね
残念ですけどもね 人参茹でても
ああ 米が米になったと
とだったらもう世の中でどうもうどうしようもなくなっちゃうんで
むちゃくちゃで それはむちゃくちゃではない
法則があるんです ですから
リンゴの種まいた人は一人だけにリンゴは食べられるし
泥棒した人がそれなりに不幸になるし
誰かさんが泥棒したんだから私つかまることはないんです
流れが変化の流れはまあ決まってるんです
そういうわけで道徳も成り立つ
因果法則によって そういうわけで修行というものも成り立つ
修行しなくちゃいけない
じーっと待っていたってもどうにもなりませんと
他力で救われてくるかなと待っていても意味がないんだと
特にあの初期時代の宗教っていうのは
とにかくお願いする お釈迦様が現れた時代の宗教っていうのは
神様を褒め称える このヴェーダ聖典っていうのは
このもう唱えるんですからね
そこで神様が機嫌良くなって
人々に祝福を与えてくれるんだと
人間の汚い声で何か言っただけで機嫌に機嫌良くなる神様だったらね
まあまあ どう見てもろくな神様ではないんだけど
で それだったら神様はね
人間の褒め称える賛美歌を聞いて喜ぶだったら
世界一流のプロを頼んで賛美歌を歌わせなくちゃいけないでしょうし
そんなことじゃなくて
おばあさんもおじいさんも
もう喉がまるっきり音痴な人も歌うんだから
で 神様は大変喜びましたと
で まあまあ笑っちゃいますけど
まあしょうがないんですけど
とにかくこのお釈迦様の時代であったのは
そういうふうにこの神様を褒め称えることなんですね
主にあった修行法というのは
それでは心は清らにならないんだと
自分で励みましょうと
自分で励んだところでなんでよくなるかというと
無常だからよくなるんです
無常だからよくなるはずなんですね
実体があれば無常にはならない
ですからお釈迦様 無我という概念
後で作った 作ったというより
後で使わす使わすにいられなかったんだけど
それはすべてはこのダイナミズムであって
変化していて無常ですよという同じ言葉なんですね
それでヒンドゥーの人々は
インド文化の人々はやっぱり何といっても何かあるんじゃないかなと捕まって囚われていたんだから
お釈迦様は兄弟にものすごく
この この何といいますか
爆発的に爆弾でも起こすような感じで
囚われるものは何もないんだと
全部捨てろということを言ったところで
あの 5人の比丘たちは悟ったんですね
で そこら辺で話を終了させていただきますけど
来月も同じテーマは続きますので
来月は このお釈迦様は
この 5人比丘たちに教えた経典に基づいて
無我論についてもうちょっとわかり
もっとわかりやすいと思いますけどね
説明いたします どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]